so there was a social media summit at
the White House last week and over the
weekend I got so many messages from
people saying David you've got to talk
about it your boy Tim Poole was there it
was really this hilarious comedy of
errors it was punctuated most
hysterically actually by Twitter not
only not being invited to the social
media summit but Twitter's platform
actually went down during the summit and
became inaccessible so nobody could
tweet about what was going on is it was
happening for a whole bunch of the time
because Twitter was down I mean it's
seriously the stuff of legend but let's
actually break through let's break it
down piece by piece a little bit so
first of all the entire premise of the
summit was that Donald Trump believes
that conservative voices are being
targeted in silence by social media it's
not just Donald Trump who believed this
there's a huge contingent of the right
that believes that conservative voices
are being targeted and silenced by
Twitter by YouTube by Facebook they're
all left-wing as far as this conspiracy
theory goes and Donald Trump reportedly
told the room of people such innovative
and amazing insights as quote some of
you are extraordinary the crap you think
of is unbelievable and yet Facebook
wasn't invited
Google wasn't invited Twitter wasn't
invited but Donald Trump did say during
the summit that he would soon invite
them and that he would scold them in
person for the liberal bias that Donald
Trump believes that they exhibit so many
of the complaints from the right are
about the moderation of content but of
course the attendees to the summit
itself were required to submit their
questions in advance of the social media
summit if they wanted to say anything
independent journalist Tim Poole who
I've interviewed and know personally was
one of the invitees and he posted some
hilarious stuff from it including these
oversized boards with definitions for
words like shadow banning daxing D
platforming and D monetization which the
sign for D monetization describes is
preventing people from earning money for
their content based on political
viewpoints of platforms which of course
we have widely debunked the YouTube D
monetization that's going
and that is affecting us and the deep
prioritization of our content on YouTube
I have not seen any evidence that it's
politically biased and what if I thought
even remotely that that was the case I
would be saying
YouTube is de prioritizing and D
monetizing left-wing content like mine
but that would be dishonest I don't
believe that that's the case I don't
believe that what's going on is
politically biased it appears to be
biased against independent creators and
towards legacy establishment corporate
creators on the basis of just being safe
for big brands to advertise on so we've
talked about that already that's another
joke but then the funniest part again
was Twitter being down globally for
about an hour during the event so
there's some farcical elements here
there's the entire premise of the event
being conservatives are being widely
censored online and there's obvious
political bias against conservatives and
towards progressives online which is a
joke we are a great example of the
reality that that's not the case we've
talked about this many times before as
I've said previously just because a
company has sort of a center-left
culture or says hey you've got to use
the gender pronouns that people want to
be called by at work that doesn't mean
that the companies are inherently
left-wing in terms of their place and
the corporate status quo this would be
like saying that in 1962 a company that
had a policy that said we don't allow
calling black people the n-word oh
that's a liberally biased company that
it's ridiculous okay
number two the people selected for this
social media summit make the event truly
laughable I mean look at the list there
was a conspiracy theorist named Bill
Mitchell who promoted queuing on
conspiracy theories online that was
invited to the White House some guy
behind a pro Trump meme account on
Twitter that does nothing of actual
journalistic or socio political or
cultural commentary value Brent Bozell
who is one of the most storied
right-wing ideologues who once compared
Barack Obama to a skinny ghetto
crackhead he was invited as some kind of
media
project Veritas which completely flopped
where the bogus so-called investigation
into Planned Parenthood selling baby
parts was invited and then a smattering
of more established right-wing groups
I'm not mentioning everyone but I think
you sort of get the gist of it so to say
you want to figure out social media and
then you invite arranged of basically
whacked-out conservatives to centrists
it's terrible I told Tim Poole we were
chatting before the event and I said Tim
it would be really great if you showed
up and you said to Trump hey we really
should have had progressives here if you
can even by the way get yourself on
video mentioning you should have had
David Pakman here we would obviously
play that on the show that's just my
personal bias but in any case say
something about the total lack of
political diversity here other than
going basically from the center to the
extreme right I don't believe that that
happened but zoom out here a little bit
and you see the hilarious hypocrisy of
the event they hold an event to talk
about the supposed suppression of
conservative voices by social media they
invite no one that has actually being
been banned they suppress even
center-left
voices nevermind progressive ones and
they demand that everybody submit their
questions ahead of time effectively
putting in place the same type of
moderation that they criticize the right
won't even understand the absurdity of
this but this is sort of like the joke
that's no longer funny this is
weaponized ignorance as I've been saying
and it's inside the White House the
White House in this case is the source
of it rather than just the place that is
unable to deal what with what it is that
is going on out on social media and on
the Internet so I I couldn't tell you
one thing that was gained from doing
this other than seeing the just
hilarious
the hilariously inaccurate way in which
the White House claims to understand or
interpret what it is that's going out
there on social media